Donald Trump is at best being played by
the Russians like the proverbial
two-dollar banjo Donald Trump is at
worst the spokesmodel of the Russians in
this country fronting for their dictator
plaid amir putin there is now evidence
of this not just trump's advocacy of
putin's dubious poll approval numbers
nor his admiration for his leadership
style nor his excuses for the opponents
and reporters jailed or hurt or worse on
putin's watch there is now evidence of
this and it does not even require
invoking the name of the shadowy
investor carter page nor the Russian
bureaucrat believed to be in charge of
his government's efforts to intervene in
our presidential election this is much
simpler and much stupider and it
reinforces my oldest theory that the
democracy survives not as much because
of the efforts and sacrifice of the
noble to preserve it as it does because
of the sloppiness and imbecility of
those who seek to destroy it on october
21st 2015 newsweek printed a story
called benghazi biopsy by a very good
writer and reporter named Kurt Ayten
Wald Benghazi the lone obsession fully
shared by the Republicans and the right
wing and the alt-right and Donald Trump
I can Walled wrote one important point
has been universally acknowledged by the
nine previous reports about Benghazi the
attack was almost certainly preventable
Clinton was in charge of the State
Department and it failed to protect US
personnel at an American consulate in
Libya if the GOP wants to raise that as
a talking point against her it is
legitimate on Monday of this week the
tenth Sputnik an online news and radio
service created by one of Russia's
government controlled news agencies
posted what it called a major revelation
from the emails stolen by WikiLeaks from
the hacked account of Clinton campaign
chairman John Podesta Sputnik claimed
that in one Podesta email Sidney
Blumenthal the other shared obsession of
the whole spectrum of right-wingers had
secretly written that Benghazi was
preventable
Sputnik claimed Sidney Blumenthal had
written this one important point that
has been universally acknowledged by
nine previous reports about Benghazi the
attack was almost certainly preventable
Clinton was in charge of the State
Department and it
failed to protect US personnel at an
American consulate in Libya if the GOP
wants to raise that as a talking point
against her it is legitimate said
Blumenthal it's exactly what Kurt I can
Walt wrote in Newsweek a year ago - one
use of the article V otherwise it is
word-for-word what Kurt I can Wald wrote
WikiLeaks stole out of John Podesta Z
emails and Sputnik published as
something Sidney Blumenthal said well
that's a hell of a coincidence of course
it isn't a coincidence a blue and Thal
email included those words because
Blumenthal was emailing I can Wald's a
story he didn't say them he didn't write
them if they go from Podesta's hacked
email account to a Russian propaganda
site and are then presented to the world
as a blockbuster confession from Sidney
Blumenthal a fake blockbuster designed
to alter the outcome of our presidential
election brought to you by WikiLeaks and
the propaganda arm of the Russian
government but it gets worse than that
and it gets scarier than that and here
is where Donald Trump is either
knowingly serving as an agent for the
Russians spreading disinformation or
he's just a [ __ ] reading stuff he
doesn't understand that somebody found
on the Internet
Trump addressing a crowd wilkes-barre
Pennsylvania hours after the sputnik
misrepresentation went online on Monday
of this week so Blumenthal writes a
quote this just came out a little while
ago I have to tell you this one
important point has been universally
acknowledged by the nine previous
reports about Benghazi this is Sidney
Blumenthal the only one she was talking
to she wasn't talking to ambassador
Stevens even though 600 calls probably
desperation the attack was almost
certainly preventable Clinton was in
charge of the State Department and it
failed to protect the United States
personnel at an American consulate in
Libya Trump said he meant Benghazi if
the GOP wants to raise that as a talking
point against her it is legitimate in
other words he's now admitting they
could have done something about Benghazi
this just came out a little while ago
Trump was reading the paragraph from the
curtain I can Walled article in Newsweek
falsely and obviously turned by the
Russians into a fake Sidney Blumenthal
quote and shoved under this idiot
Trump's nose
he read it aloud and the crowd started
chanting lock her up Donald Trump speech
is infused with propaganda from the
Russian government but why should you
think that and not that it could be a
coincidence or just the typical sloppy
thinking of a slob like Trump because of
a very strange man named Roger stone
Roger stone is a longtime Trump
confidante and he had been a formal
adviser to this campaign stone tweets on
Sunday October to quote Wednesday at
Hillary Clinton is done hashtag
WikiLeaks the next day I have total
confidence that at WikiLeaks and my hero
Julian Assange will educate the American
people soon hashtag lock her up but
neither of those is a smoking gun in
fact Assange is much touted news
conference became instead a late-night
web video appearance at which he sold
WikiLeaks books and besides that if they
like stone actually specifically
referenced John Podesta or anything oh
right he did on August 21st stone had
tweeted trust me it will soon the sick
Podesta's time in the barrel
I can Walt writes it WikiLeaks hacks
Podesta's email stone menaces Podesta
stone promises Clinton is done thanks to
WikiLeaks WikiLeaks produces an email I
can Walt's article is misidentified by
the Russians of something Sidney
Blumenthal said and Trump reads it to
the red meat crowd hours later like a
good puppet and it sure looks like stone
knew it was all going to happen six
weeks ago he knew only he was too stupid
to keep his mouth shut and the Russians
were too stupid to realize that a guy
who really wrote the quotes would
recognize his own words when he read
them and on top of everything else Trump
then complained because it was not the
October Surprise he had been promised
Wednesday 946 am very little picked up
by the dishonest media of incredible
information provided by WikiLeaks so
dishonest rigged system true rigged only
the system in question is Vladimir
Putin's democracy survives not as much
because of the efforts and sacrifice of
the noble to preserve it as it does
because of the sloppiness
in facility of those who seek to destroy
it kindly pray that this continues to be
true that's the closure I'm Keith
Olbermann watch this space